it's tougher to be the bachelor these
days the bachelor historically and
something i don't agree with how they do
it they like they like showing a boy
could become a man and i think that's
been to their detriment in recent years
you know i think clayton is a great guy
i think i've gotten to know him but i do
think he went in very immature susie's
great for him but unfortunately the show
hasn't like recognized that what the
[ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sistine stallone do we just become best
friends yup
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sisters sophia and
sistine sophia that was a really good
acting job thank you i'm giving you 98
on rotten tomatoes i'm smiling on the
outside but i'm sleeping on the inside
yeah you're really tired i have to say i
mean we've had it crazy last month which
we'll get into but
your tiredness i will accept today i
know i know i know i know people are
gonna say oh but like the last part of
the trip was relaxing it was granted but
at the same time hahaha uh but you know
it's like basically we're in new york we
all know that you see some episodes that
we had released previously you started
your trip in new york
you did too no
see i was i've been gone the entire
month i've never actually traveled for a
full month so you started your i started
my trip in new york new york yeah
i was in oklahoma for a week before that
against my will
it was not exciting i was not against
your will at all you're acting like
everyone forced you to go to oklahoma
you can get on a plane yourself and walk
there tell me this
riddle me this sophia
what do you do in oklahoma
i don't know i've never been yeah
that's all you do what's the problem
with that there's no problem but man on
your fourth meal at a dive bar you're
like enough i know you're with mom dad
he was working on set you you act like
that was like the worst experience at
all
no but it wasn't the worst experience i
almost felt like an unpaid dog sitter
the whole time right that's really all i
could do there was and there were a lot
of dogs
there's clean up their poo poo
it was a lot but whatever go on with
what you were saying well no then we
both ended up in new york yes we met up
there um and we shot on wax for a week
which was really fun i stayed with my
boyfriend who's from there and she was
with scarlett who was there and my dad
was also there shooting which was super
fun so it was a family affair i know and
that was totally unplanned and i don't
think we've all been
working at the same place the same
scholar just came for pleasure to watch
us and cheers on and i think also to go
try some scarlet classic new york baby
girls because that was her just low-key
finesse her way to going to new york
yeah she was like i really really really
want to come and support you guys i'm
thinking yeah okay that's like really
sweet did we see her once though she was
she was like a new york rat just running
running around never saw her once no
barely barely barely but that was really
fun that was a lot of fun i definitely
want to do that trip again i feel like
there are so many
more guests that i'd love to have on oh
honey but we didn't even get the chance
to do so maybe we'll do that sooner or
later and then after that we part ways
again no we ended up in both florida for
a second for one day i stay in florida
for another week and then you go to
cabo
mexico mexico and that was so much fun
and the reason why i said the last part
was relaxing but not relaxing is because
i was with the boyfriend's family so you
know when it's your first trip with them
you want to make sure that everything is
to the nines like you want to make it
perfect that you're on it because you
don't know them they don't know you and
you have to figure out this middle
ground of okay how much do i involve
myself in the conversation and how do i
pull back where i'm not
overbearing or over sharing or being
annoying and then also not being a
recluse where i don't want to be a part
of the family yes dynamic you know going
on a trip with your significant other's
family for the first time i feel like
the second time you're pretty much your
toes in the water you're already warm
with it it's like the hunger games any
wrong step you blow up yeah they're
grenades everywhere i'm not saying that
they're planting them on purpose
but you never know
no i'll tell you this i'm not accusing
that family of planting anything
but have i subconsciously also not
subconsciously set your boyfriends up
for a po like you know i give them like
trial questions to see how they'll
answer yeah they have invisible strength
seeing if they trip or not yeah they're
they've noticed the string laser beams
yeah i've been playing they cross it and
if there's an alarm they're not it so do
you think it was successful oh yeah i
killed it i'm great at this stuff the
problem is is that it takes
everything out of me so it's not only
the whole trip from new york and then
flying to florida fly to l.a flying a
combo and everyone's like yeah that
sounds like horrible yeah i got it but
it's still a lot of energy you're
putting into it and for me
my personality i put a lot of thought
yeah and thought into everything
literally i don't know if you can see
this the scene i have oh my god on your
arms you gotta buy some trucker jackets
i know i have hives on my arms just from
the entire weeks leading up and i think
i'm just back home and i'm
so
you've hit a wall i've heard and that's
i think a really bad habit that you do
and i am definitely guilty of this is we
try to do the most especially with
people that aren't our family because we
want them to like us so much yes you're
exuding all this energy and i gave you
the advice before you left i was like
sophia you're a guest in their home so
you can also sit back and let them
entertain you like you don't need to be
the dancing man yeah i guess not
entertain me but also not expect me to
say like let's do this and like be like
the it's not because i don't know what's
going on
yeah exactly i'm just the guest and
overall though the trip to cabo the
ocean amazing i don't remember swimming
that much in my entire life that's all
in the water the sun was awesome i got a
heat rash after the last day all over my
chest because i was in the sun so much
it was so cute but i had tacos
margaritas it was awesome and i was with
him and so the family is amazing and
he's great and the the scenery was
awesome but i definitely am really
looking forward to downtime me time for
the next like two weeks i'm watching a
spider crawl up this pillow right now
and what is the scene's biggest fear two
spiders deep water and philosophia which
by the way phobia which spiders by the
way yeah it was scarlett's birthday that
we celebrated in palm beach yeah explain
what happened in palm beach because
there wasn't much that happened it was a
pretty slow um it was low season there
so there wasn't a lot of people but mom
and scarlet were like let's go to the
beach for scarlett's birthday and i said
great and scarlett and mom go into the
ocean and like the scene why are you
sitting on the sand like a kid who can't
swim i'm like because i'm a kid who
can't swim they're like oh come on you
can swim yeah false i can swim but i
can't tread very well no and the waves
were crazy and i just started getting
that thalassophobia just like creeping
when i tell you again she really just
can't tread water for longer than 10
seconds and then she starts
you only see her head peering from the
water which is ironic because a lot of
people will say well like weren't you in
like
a shark movie where you were swimming
for nine hours a day yeah
but y'all there are flotation devices on
me i don't actually have to tread
yeah i was wearing a live jacket she
always has a floaty somewhere around
here yeah and then i start laughing when
she doesn't have one and i travel we
should help you more than actually you
start pulling me down if i'm next to you
get on your back she sits on my back but
i have to figure out that one day i was
in florida my mom wanted to shop for
scarlett's birthday and the funniest
thing was happening to sistine in the
makeup department yeah
can i just say that from my perspective
i was there looking at the perfumes saw
sistine looked away
not even three minutes later she comes
in looking like bows of the clown
clown it was the [ __ ] so upset i'm
actually triggered right now and i'm
pissed if you're watching this guy from
the makeup department in palm beach that
was not cool so you know when you're
browsing in a department store all the
makeup and then you get the sales people
that try to sell you on a product and
then you can kind of say like oh no
thank you i'm just browsing and they
leave you alone like it's not a big deal
right i've never met this guy should be
a politician yeah he was so persistent
and i can't say no to people no he first
starts
oh my god this is his lime he was so
clever he goes oh my god who did your
makeup it looks so good and i go
come on man you know i did my makeup
like what do you think i'm not gonna get
my makeup done every day so sue how
would he know that you did your makeup
why would you assume on a regular
tuesday that i got my makeup done in the
middle of the day just making some
speech i mean no but it makes no sense
that was a clever line he hooked me in
so now i'm having a conversation with
him
you know we should take notes for like
dating like this is actually really
smart yeah so he hooks me in so now i'm
conversing with him found a commonality
exactly and i was like no you know i did
my makeup and he goes oh my god it looks
fantastic you know i would love to do
your makeup i'm a licensed professional
makeup artist and i'm like oh cool
that's a good connect like good to know
and he goes you know your skin tone you
have some like olive yellow undertones
have you ever tried this and i'm like oh
no you know
10 minutes go by
and i still can't say no to this guy and
i still can't leave he has bright orange
blush all over my face not a little bit
on my forehead all over my face
everywhere and then this is the gag and
i was upset because i really liked my
makeup that day ruined it
he goes have you ever tried blue mascara
and look
i'm not knocking anyone that likes blue
mascara i think when someone wears it
i'm like that's cool right me however
she's the biggest eyes ever you think
that that would be the best thing for
her is to make them even bigger no yeah
i look like a scary doll
she looks like actual um the real no
what's it called that coraline no
annabelle oh and a real annabelle
thank you yeah
anyway are you saying i'm young do i
look porcelain yeah sure
or stuffed all but okay whatever i kind
of look like a doll today actually
anyway so
he puts on this blue mascara
don't know why i couldn't say no at this
point but i've committed to it and i
looked like a girl that had been raving
at edm for about 28 hours but not only
that is so
bad my eyebrows are huge he made them
even bigger he goes you want a brook
shield and then [ __ ] put like
brown eyeshadow and just with his
fingers go
have you seen uh shit's creek have you
seen american pie the guy that plays the
dad in both of those he's great the
biggest eyebrows this chick has ever had
in mind
i see a lifeline walk by me scarlett and
i go yes this is my out and i was like
hey scarlett this is my little sister
uh mom wanted us upstairs right i think
we need to go upstairs i'm trying
anything to get away from this guy
because
i can't say no to his stunning face like
he was just
annoying so
his scummy face was he cute well like
you could tell this band took great care
of his skin like it was just perfection
yeah stunning so
scarlett looks at me
gives me a cheeky little smile and goes
no mom doesn't need us
sistine this color would actually look
really good on you this guy's like yes
this
plum purple lipstick would look great on
you i was like [ __ ]
me i walk back over turn around and
sistine is not sustained i go who is
this girl she looks like literally the
clown on sunset thank you we get it
clown clown clown we got it sophia god
anyway so i go excuse me one moment i
walk away i go to sofia i leave scarlet
at the counter
and i go
fend for yourself my sisters were not my
sister five minutes later scarlet's
giving me these help me eyes and i just
give her a little cheeky smile and i
walk away i said your turn right you're
you're done you're done you know what
i've been seeing
all over my 4u page and i know by the
time this comes out it'll probably be
old news but
top gun
oh i was gonna say i was like are you
talking about elvis or top gun because
i've seen bullets
miles teller and austin butler
everywhere let's do it let's do a pros
which one do we like better miles teller
but he's oh that was easy
why
i don't know he's just more the look i
would
you'd go for and i think he's a really
great actor well he's splash have you
seen project x
have you seen he was in public
when you're not a real fan anyway so
right now tick tock is blowing up
because he's just getting thirsted his
body is chef's kiss indeed and then
suddenly his current wife
they're gonna get broken up
suddenly like posting all of these tick
tocks i don't know first trapping her
own husband being like sorry ladies yeah
exactly like trying to remind everybody
he's with me this rainbow wedding photo
i get it i'm like fair i would have done
the same no i don't get it actually look
if that was my husband and the whole
internet is going crazy for how
attractive he is i would just be sitting
there with my cup of tea on the couch
feeling like yeah that's mine i don't
need to make a public psa like
yeah ladies this is it he's not like
this whole thing
you don't need to claim we know i know i
know i saw her tick tocks from before
all these thirst traps came out and they
were like over a year ago and then
suddenly these tick tocks come out and
she's like posted three in a row i mean
maybe i'm just jealous yeah i don't know
we sound a little bitter i'll be like
yeah but but you said the elvis film did
really well yes so at the cannes film
festival which i'm a huge fan of that
festival i feel like that
the outfits there are way better dressed
than at the met yeah everyone always
kills their looks at the canned film
festival which has you know it has
nothing to do with fashion
it's all about just kills it just kills
it so elvis was uh the film premiered
there and it got a 12 minute standing
ovation
that's insane i know and i have to wait
another month to watch it you know what
i it makes me so happy i
yeah there's been some good films but i
feel like there hasn't been
that many good films in the last few
years where everyone was talking about
it and now i'm hearing and but fun like
not just
oscar nominated stuff like that
obviously those are just well thought
out beautifully shot but they can be
kind of boring for honest but i heard
top gun was one of the best action films
and i also heard elvis was amazing so
it's really nice to see these videos
that people generally would want to
watch anyways
actually turned out well and better than
people expected especially their remakes
and remakes are really hard well i have
to say i feel like a common theme with
films that always
are so successful when all these awards
which by the way they're saying austin
butler is up for an oscar which wow
amazing that'd be great they are always
around music
yeah bohemian rhapsody because they're
fun they're people that the elton john
film rocket man top gun not really but i
guess the the soundtrack is a classic
soundtrack so everyone's going to want
to hear all that stuff but yeah i'm
really excited to see those two films
that's going to be really fun why they
both taken
tell me this
well what am i saying riddle
me sorry
anyway
um i was actually doing something uh
quite
funny yesterday which is
you know
i found my old journal and i'm not gonna
call it a diary because that's cringy
and that's ick yeah but i found my old
journal and i i found this journal which
only had two pages written in it and i
only did it because you told me to start
journaling right and this is from
probably two years ago so i find my old
journal right and i read the two pages
that i wrote mm-hmm and when i was
writing them
i remember feeling like i was crying on
the pages i remember feeling so sad but
reading them now
like wrinkled yeah there's like a little
stain on it
it is so embarrassing
like i it was comical reading back how
like sad and depressed i thought i was
over some stupid guy i'm like oh come on
i
love journals do i love journaling all
the time no but when i feel a wave of
emotion i start just jotting down
everything that i'm feeling and i used
to read back on these things but i have
at least three different journals
yeah i love writing my thoughts out um
not like i don't talk them out anyways
on a podcast to friends everywhere i go
to myself in the shower but i would go
back and read these old journal entries
and yeah i would see like wow i was
really upset but i started to see
patterns of what i would do in the past
especially with like relationships or
friendships or my thought process of oh
wait i get really upset towards this
time when i'm looking this way or when
i'm with this person or whatever it is
um and especially when i came to a
relationship that's kind of like how a
lot of my decisions were based
um for like what i wanted to do next
based on how i felt in that moment in
the past you know what i'm saying 100
i think it's really interesting how
when you do read back these old entries
you can actually see on paper the
development and the growth that you've
had since you last wrote it and
it kind of teaches you like okay even
though in that moment i was feeling my
lowest i was feeling really down i was
so sad i felt like i couldn't get out of
this hole and now reading it back when
you're out of this hole and you don't
have those same emotions you're like
okay it gives you hope things always get
better they get better they can get
worse they can get okay but it's never
the same feeling no it's never the same
feeling every single day is completely
different or every month is totally
different yes but it's great um okay we
have our guests here
so you guys we are so excited to have on
this guest i know we see it every time
but we are always equally excited for
every guest but this one in particular
we've been really wanting he's like a
podcast guru relationship expert we've
been following him on tv for years i
cannot believe he's about to sit on this
couch and
drops some major knowledge relationship
tea all of that good stuff we want to
hear from the men's point of view so
stay tuned
[Music]
you may remember this charming
heartthrob from being the leading man on
the bachelor he was taking names falling
in love and breaking hearts but since
then he became the ceo and founder of
natural habits and created his wildly
popular podcast called the vile files
where he offers excellent relationship
advice having over 400 episodes recorded
and more than 80 million downloads he is
clearly saying something right and we
are definitely here to listen this is
nick vile studio audience
[Applause]
um you clap for yourself sometimes yeah
all the
time for yourself
um
can't believe you're here yeah by the
way you're excited first impression when
you walked in i saw on your instagram
bio you said taller in person yeah i
actually looked up at you i was like
holy [ __ ] did i live up to that i'll
tell you six two right yeah it's just
like when i first i think i apparently
appear short on tv or i don't know do
people come up to you say that a lot
less now but definitely when i
i mean i still get it but like at the
height of like bachelor
nation time i mean that would always be
the first thing out of people's minds is
like wow you're actually talking i would
blame the cameraman i'm like either
you're shooting from up down and you're
just making me look bad but i also think
maybe it's just like something it
made you realize just like
the i guess the privileged tall people
are rewarded right because you know
especially
i was you know my first time on the show
like the villain and so a lot of people
yeah like didn't like me and i think
when they like met me and then they saw
a tall person i was like oh well you're
tall so you must be like
maybe we maybe
yeah it's actually it's fine without the
assumption if you're tall you must be
like no it was just like the way people
would say it they would be like oh
you're taller than persons if it wasn't
something about my personality
all of like the the evil thing that they
put on you before it's like oh wait no
he's not gonna
assess what i said about you because
you're tall that's absolutely fatty
i definitely want to talk about your
time on the bachelor because you joined
the show in was it 2014 14 yeah 2014.
and you know you're tall you're a
handsome dude i would assume you have no
problem finding women so why join a show
that ends in marriage well i don't think
anyone actually goes for love
t
t yeah i don't know if that's is it no
it's not she bothers me
i actually wrote that down was i do you
think the i mean like i don't think the
bachelor franchise is now necessarily
about finding love anymore i feel like
it's more for like exposure yeah i mean
it's more so now than ever before
because of social media but even when i
went on like instagram existed it wasn't
what it is now um but you're kind of you
have to be a little nutty and insane to
truly say i'm going for love like i
think you have to be open for love like
i when i went i was like i went because
i had never been to europe and they're
like you get to travel and i was like
cool
not about it it's fun free flights
but i think when you go there are people
who once you go are then open to it and
like embrace the process and say well
i'm here so like i'll i'll see what this
can be
and actually develop feelings which i
was one of those people right and other
people like don't kind of embrace the
atmosphere they're in but like
to say like i don't think any sane
person
signs up because they're like you know
what
i can't find love in the ass right right
i haven't had luck in the bars you know
what you know what's going to save me
what's the worst that could happen
that's a little nutty but i mean i
signed up i mean i didn't sign up my my
friend's wife signed me up and that's
right that's how i ended up yeah i was
gonna ask like how that whole thing
started were you open to it once like
she
she signed me up because i was making
fun of her for watching the show
and she signed me up as a joke it's
karma and then they they called me six
months later and i only say yes i only
said yes to the casting process because
at that point i'd
i'd never been to la and i was like this
seems intere i mean i thought the
casting process would be interesting so
i thought like i'll just go through the
casting process yeah you seem like a
very curious person because this would
be fun yeah you're just like why not
like why not um but i had no
anticipation of saying yes i had
recently got promoted at my job and i
just didn't think
i would be able to
and then as i went to the casting
process i realized that they like they
might cast me because at first i was
like i'll just go through it you know
i'm sure they won't be interested in me
like but this will just be neat right
and
pretty quickly they were like no we
like the casting people loved me yeah
that there's a lot of steps to go
through how many steps did it take to
actually get on the show three or four i
don't remember we've had it's not that
agreed yeah but like at when i first i
first met cat the casting people in
chicago because they're like we're gonna
be in chicago we'd love to meet you
and i met them and they were
they they just like made me feel like
they were
interested in me right and at that point
as i went through the casting process i
started
uh talking to people i trusted at work
right like well like
what do you think yeah it's this crazy
thing i got like i would never do it
hypothetically to my surprise everyone
was like no you have to [ __ ] do that
really like oh wow so i never would have
done it if it weren't for some of the
the support you got the support at work
and like leadership at work who
thankfully i was good at my job and they
were just a big believer at like
work-life balance and so is there a boss
a big bachelor fan
no they just
i think you know they were familiar with
the show none of my like bosses were but
i think all their like wives probably
watched i think they were just
fascinated by it i thought it was cool
right and thankfully i was at a company
that supported that kind of balance
right and um
you know
from there you have a really interesting
story with your experience in the
bachelor because not only were you a
contestant competing against other men
you were the bachelor and you had about
what 30 women you were dating at one
time it's a lot i mean i kind of want to
hear what it was like in both positions
for you
was it really competitive when you're up
against all these guys or was it just
sort of catty like it is sort of with
women competing after one guy both i
think it's both caddy and competitive
right
um like uh it's it's very high school
right so like i think the biggest reason
why i was
considered the villain on season one is
because well one they didn't
i've been told this they didn't do a
good job casting that season
so it was just a very growy season right
and
a lot
everyone just like enjoyed growing out
and
drinking right and i'm not a big drinker
i mean i'll drink but i'm not like a big
fan of like i'm not gonna shock him
in the bro yeah and then i really liked
her and now to my surprise and like she
liked me
and
i
like i made the mistake of like taking
it seriously to be honest you know i was
like oh i like her he wanted to work but
you actually did the premise of the show
and then
yeah and so then i it was just it's just
more of a fish out of water type of
thing and so it gets really petty and
competitive and
yeah they play on people's insecurities
you know if you don't get validated it's
easier to
assume it's something else someone else
is doing right rather than something you
aren't aren't
told that you are aren't doing and
that's how they you know cause when you
were casted as quote the villain do you
think they sort of manipulated
situations and conversations to make you
look like the bad guy uh i mean
not really i listen the producers
produce for sure right and like i've had
my frustrations with them they know that
but i i i'm i think they're often a
scapegoat for cast members to complain
about things when things don't go their
way 100 percent most like the the
producers who engage with cass aren't
the ones who edit the show right you
know and so
they're just filming hours and hours of
content yeah and
you know like you don't when you're
going through it like there was a moment
towards the end of the season i was like
i think i might be able to villain you
know
only because like a bunch of the guys
were like randomly getting mad at me and
i was like why what am i doing what am i
doing you know but they're like yelling
at me yeah um but but up into that point
you really don't know how it's the story
is going to be told
i mean they're they're
they're filming say like 40 hours for
every episode they're filming 40 hours
and using an hour and a half i know it's
crazy or two hours for an hour and a
half if you've considered like
commercials or whatever right so you
really don't know so i i don't it's it's
more you know a lot has to do with like
the soundtrack they're using and things
like that they don't have to do all that
much but
all the producers are trying to do is to
get people to say exactly how they feel
yeah in the moment i always describe
them as the friend who wants you to buy
the boat
right that's actually such a good way to
put it because they're they want they're
gonna be close to you but they're gonna
encourage you to like maybe go up
confront say something just yeah they
still and but they want but it's for
their benefit too yeah they they don't
have their long you don't have their
they don't have your long term yeah
they're like the boat's gonna be really
fun for the weekend
at the end like you're the have fun yeah
we'll all bring the beer if you buy them
i won't be there to clean it up and it
probably won't appreciate very well and
it's gonna be a pain in the ssl and
it'll probably break down and people
might not be happy with you but but fun
but fun
so i was after the show um did people
were people upset with you after that
like no because i feel like obviously
people have to see that it is a show
like i mean there is things that can
manipulate but maybe people take it
super seriously uh i think i lucked out
to
you know because social media existed
but again wasn't what it was
so
yeah i i actually my experience was
relatively positive that's great like i
was living in chicago at the time and so
chicago being a midwest city who who
aren't necessarily used to seeing
any type of celebrities so when a
reality tv personality rocks in from the
bachelor like
i walk into a bar and feel like a rock
star damn everyone was just very you
know excited that i was tall and very
nice
he's not evil so i definitely like yeah
i mean it was all it was like in person
everyone's nice there was you know
certainly a couple i've had a couple
instances where people would say weird
or awkward things but whatever but it
was all in that positive
and
like okay so let's put your let's put
the shoe on the other foot now you're
the bachelor and i wouldn't even would
you consider it dating 30 women at once
no no okay so you're just
interviewing you're surviving 30 women
at once
i can barely sit through a two-hour date
without feeling completely depleted i
don't know how you can have so many
conversations how did you do that in one
night and also be able to separate each
girls differently and not compare their
names they you have a producer helping
night one
okay i'd say nametag see i had a theory
and i asked caitlyn bristow this and i
said when you they're doing the rose
ceremony every single time
when they're about to hand out the rose
they look down at the rose i'm like
there must be a name there's no name no
okay no it's really something they you
you did she tell you how it goes
she did she says you go back they do so
usually they they're like all right they
give you four names at a time right but
they're like they're like how much it's
like more of like a fun memory game
they're like
the truth is
like if when you're there for the first
time you don't know what the [ __ ]
going on right so you're there in this
really quiet room like when you're
watching and there's this music and then
when you're there there's no music
you're like this is weird and there's
all these cameras
so when when the lead walks in and out
you're just like what the [ __ ] going
on like maybe they're confused maybe
they're still deciding you don't really
know oh no meanwhile they just don't
remember they still remember the name so
the producers are just like they'll give
you four at a time and if they're like
if you forget just walk out don't say
anything
they'll it'll just scare the [ __ ] they
don't even show that part and so you're
literally probably staying there as like
one of the girls going wait he just like
walked out it's also a genius
manipulation tactic silence is the
ultimate killer yeah it's so
so yeah you would just remember four
names at a time and then walk out and
walk back in oh god i mean but i'm
trying to put myself in your shoes where
we're having these dates and i'm sure
they go all night like till the sun
rises first the first night the first
night right
and everyone's drinking wine and they're
getting a little sloshed in about four
hours in you're drinking more having
their 30 seconds with you
and and then you have to like my biggest
thing is just bad hygiene and then you
probably have to kiss one and you're
like what yeah what like white wine
breath is a real oh that's what i was
saying i'm trying to get that i was
thinking about that that's a really they
have like listerine strips because you
don't want to chew gum on set that's
hysterical so listerine strips i think
uh the bachelor franchise is like
keeping listerine strips everywhere
in the bushes
no you don't no i don't think i saw them
at all but they're they're very they're
all over this they're there but it's
still like the mixture of wine breath
and then listerines just to cover it up
still there are a couple times you're
like she needs a mint oh that is so
funny but you know like you don't
realize because like you know they're
there all night they're nervous you're
drinking yeah you know like it's
no you don't realize you don't realize
and it's just more like a stale
everyone's breathing oh god my goodness
so
part of dating or you know facing all
these women is often dealing with
rejection
is it
worse on tv is it easier because you
know it's sort of a show well it depends
on who you are yeah you know i think
i think half the cast pretty quickly
like will recognize that like i don't
think the leads into me oh you know yeah
you kind of you can pull energy between
someone yeah yeah and then there's like
a middle pack where
like they're the front runners feel like
there's no way they're like there's like
always like two or three front runners
mm-hmm yeah and they and in their mind
they think there's
i don't
what yeah there's no connections going
on right and there's like a middle of a
pack people but no everyone only knows
their story right right and
everyone's meant to believe that
the lead is very much into them
and so it's just a matter of how much
bs do you want to convince yourself to
feel validated do you feel like you can
tell early on the three people that are
like the most
i it's hard for me to answer that
honestly just because like with andy i
got the first impression rose and i was
i felt pretty validated by her early on
and with caitlyn i showed up late but i
had i kind of knew her so like for me
yes i knew pretty quickly yeah yeah but
i think most people can tell i think
i think the women when they're competing
for the bachelor's affection i think
they're more intuitive and i think they
seem to pick up on it yeah a little more
right right right of who the bachelor
favorites are
can you is it really possible because i
know you had some comments about the
whole clayton season i i stopped
watching the bachelor franchise a little
bit because i just didn't feel like it
was the same as it used to be but then i
watched that and i said yeah you were
the last good season
right here
honestly but uh it's tougher to be the
basher these days it is it is and then
he does it and then i mean i i just
watched it because of the whole thing
that happened at the end with him
falling in love tech yeah i guess with
three words
that was pretty i told the three women
is that possible yeah because can you
focus you were there outside of the
franchise did you not fall could you
fall in love with it i don't personally
think so but like you know everyone
defines love differently right and the
bachelor historically and something i
don't agree with how they do it
uh historically they liked casting a
bachelor
like i was not their typical bachelor
right they love historically casting a
bachelor they like they like showing a
boy become a man on their
right
right right so they love the i've never
been in love or very inexperienced
totally and i think that's been to their
detriment in recent years because i
think the audience
and it used to work but the audience
with heightened expectations of dating
yeah and and the struggles just people
are having with dating especially women
who are you know a large part of their
audience
no one wants to see a boy yeah like find
love and you know i think clayton is a
great guy i think i've gotten to know
him but i do think he went in very
immature i think he grew up i think he
grew up a lot 100
on the show and i think susie's great
for him but
i think unfortunately the show hasn't
like
recognized that yeah and i think it's
been to the detriment of their bachelors
because um it's not like they're getting
bad edits i just think they're kind of
getting hung out to dry yeah i think
they need to take someone totally new
that wasn't from the bachelor franchise
in the i like don't you think that it
kind of did with matt james
that's but he kind of it wasn't like he
was totally just different because he
was always in that like the whole tyler
hymn relationship was kind of viral on
instagram i mean totally someone that is
fully separated maybe older that
actually like a regular average joe i
think that could work i think they could
do a better job of actually doing the
opposite which is
i thought like a lot of people think
around my time with ben higgins yeah and
like caitlyn and jojo was like
peak bachelor it was yeah and i think
that's when they did a good job of
developing characters right so like you
were whether you liked me or didn't like
me you were invested in my story about
100 percent
and i think they've gotten away with uh
from that like they're still casting
certain people but like clayton
no one knew who the hell he was in the
shell season no no so he might have he
might as well been like someone
random from the street right so but at
the same time as great as clayton is as
a person like was he the right fit to be
the bachelor probably probably not so
i think they might need to invest a
little bit more
like
when they're casting for the
bachelorette with a more heightened
sense of like who like potentially could
be
their bachelor i think in the past they
the show shows behemoth that i think
there is a level of confidence from the
higher ups thinking we can make anyone
the bachelor right you know we can make
anyone but you can't it's up to us but i
don't think it's as easy anymore with
the expectations i think their audience
have with dating and relationships and
these and the struggles that people are
having and when they see those
frustrations on the show and they see
you know more of an immature person
they feel like why should we
right why should we root for this person
invest in this person um so yeah i mean
since being on the bachelor i think the
way that you've pivoted your career has
been quite genius and i haven't really
seen
anyone in the bachelor community
build their own name the way that you
have and do you have this incredible
podcast where you give such good
relationship dating sex advice all of
that do you account a lot of the advice
and the things that you've learned from
you know going on all of these dates or
interactions with nearly every type of
woman
not so much the show i definitely think
it helped so what how did you like i
didn't have a podcast before or after
you know after that okay but i think it
came more from my my my personal dating
life in my 20s
uh i definitely was someone who
struggled not like i didn't like i was
how would you define your 20s dating
like monogamous i had three serious
relationships wow i was i when i say
struggled i mean like not like you know
i was always
i always did fine like with attention
and i like
but i i
like i really
like loved what my parents had so i grew
up in a very conservative like
traditional family i have ten siblings
my parents like ten siblings
no where are you in the line i'm number
two oh so i was the old i'm the oldest
boy
i'm the oldest a lot of responsibility
yeah so like a catholic family i grew up
in like my parents you know like met in
their early 20s got married
and then they have a great marriage
and so i think like a lot of people
especially from like the midwest the
whole my you have this mentality of you
know go to school graduate find love
yeah i i had this girlfriend in college
i met i met her right after high school
and we dated all through college and
it was like like most people's first
relationship
had its toxic moments and we were just
like two young people it was just
innocent love who like
wanted to like you know that i fight for
love yeah but we'll make it work we'll
get through our incompatibility issues
all these things meanwhile we were also
like growing up at the same time meeting
other people you know every time she met
a guy she'd break up with me and she
wouldn't tell me that at the time
you know and
i was sitting here just like fighting
you know i was like oh i'm waiting
around and you know and i didn't i'm
sure i didn't i had my faults too and um
and then so that lasted on and off for
seven years seven years wow um we broke
up i know probably six times i broke up
with her once she broke with me every
single time except once in the middle
and then i finally took your power back
and then and i was finally finally the
one who ended it like let me try oh okay
um and then uh but only because i met
someone else
so i broke up with her and i got right
into a relationship bad idea terrible
idea yeah so how long was that
relationship for a year and a half okay
and then but you sound like you're good
at relationships i know yeah yeah
but they have their moments but you make
them last yeah i think you can learn a
lot i i you can learn a lot from failure
you can learn a lot from your mistakes
uh and then yeah we did a year and a
half we got engaged he cheated on me and
then wait how did you get over that
that's something that a lot of listeners
write in and they just don't know how
that was uh that was a pivotal point of
my life it was i i i've uh i'm very
thankful for that mm-hmm i i refer to it
as the time i met my ego
oh explain well because
when you get cheated on it's like have
you ever been cheetah yes uh she has i
have not you have so like when you first
got cheated on and the first time some
and you guys broke up yeah okay and then
the first time someone was like what
happened what did you say
well i gave specifics to what he did you
did yeah well good for you because most
people like me and yeah i'm just like i
don't know we just like it
you know like you're just embarrassed i
was just angry i was really ashamed and
embarrassed about like the thought of
like someone someone could cheat on me
yeah exactly i wasn't i never thought of
getting engaged somebody cared enough to
like yeah and i was i felt
embarrassed about it and a lot of people
including myself like when that happens
to you you feel like it's a reflection
of you right hundred percent i blamed
myself later yeah so like why how as if
like something i did or couldn't have
done and your ego is very mad at you
you're gonna say what the [ __ ] did you
do right and at that point like i never
really thought about the idea of like
having an ego and i have a big one and
we all do and i think it was just i kind
of learned that lesson of like well wait
i didn't
i mean i'm sure i played a role in our
relationship ending but yeah i didn't
cheat i wasn't so yeah you didn't and
then one and then one time i was just
like [ __ ] it i'm just next time someone
asked i'm just gonna
like once you change that okay and then
the person's responding was like oh that
was shitty over here did that give you a
sense of power though yeah for sure
because you realize well it's
i didn't it's not a reflection of who i
am yeah and it's okay to like i i
realize it's like it's okay for someone
not to like you and it's okay to be
rejected and i spent a lot of time in my
first relationship
and it like being cheated on in the
second relationship looks like to answer
your question why do i not think it was
a good idea to get a wrong relationship
because it wasn't until the second
relationship ended that i finally felt
like i was over the first relationship
okay i like loved my girlfriend my
second relationship we had a great you
know yeah yeah
they're a great time yeah but like she
goes first one was always in the back of
my mind it was seven years right i was
just like she was all i knew
right i wasn't really i told myself i
was over her because i was like oh no i
love my current girlfriend but like it
would it would pop up and i would okay
but she always popped up like i think
that's just human nature because when
you are hurt or you get out of
relationship i know i'm a victim of this
where i will jump into something right
away just to seek validation i might not
even like that person that much i know
that i'm still thinking about my ex but
why do you think people
sort of just instead of sitting with
themself and being comfortable with who
they are alone they have to you know
find someone else to give them that
sense of happiness yeah it's our our
egos yeah it's that need for validation
our egos are
i always i feel like i [ __ ] on the ego a
lot
it's a our egos are a great thing our
egos are what
make us chase our dreams to make us
think i can
i don't i'm not ordinary i can shoot for
the stars and that's our ego is gives us
the confidence to believe in ourselves
but
the rest it's like
it's a monster that can its thirst can
never be quenched
reverse it really quick you said that
you guys were engaged right yeah um did
you ever ask her why she cheated because
she's never owned up to it oh
cause i'm always curious to hear because
i've never cheated or i've never thought
about doing that like i'm always
wondering what makes someone get to that
point where they want to instead of
disrespectful that they actually have
been invested in loving it's a good
question i think for a lot of people
it's different reasons like
when you know i said she never owned up
to it my guess is she probably never
owned up to it because
she probably never slept with him
you know but they were hanging out like
the emotions like she ended up like
getting engaged she got engaged from
eight months after we broke up okay well
okay yeah like come on you can't
admit it at this point
how did you find out
all my friends told me it was like in
milwaukee like it's a small city a small
city it's like if you've done something
once like everyone uh but i didn't want
to believe him at first that's for sure
i definitely backed her at first of
course i mean like you never want to
assume the worst thing is
uh i'd be setting milwaukee on fire but
yeah you just uh i think people do it
for all different reasons again probably
ego need for validation you know they
you know some people like and again i
was that person in my 20s i felt like
being in a relationship mattered as it
related to like
my self-worth
right so every time i've if i was single
in my 20s i felt less than i felt like i
you know and that's why every time in my
first relationship we'd break up i spent
more time i didn't i didn't spend any
time thinking about
maybe this is healthy maybe maybe she
made the right choice maybe we aren't as
compatible as i want to believe that we
were yeah but i spent no time
considering that as soon as she broke up
with me it was how how can i get this
back how do i identify if i can't get
her how can i get someone else because
like if i'm single i'm a loser do you
think there was love bombing involved
because you're maybe your judgment was
clouded or you're wearing like love
bombing
or maybe maybe you were just wearing
like rose-colored lenses so you only
wanted to see the ghosts no i mean i'm
very careful about like language like
love bombing and like gaslighting like
love bombing is a manipulation tactic
that you use to like elicit a response
like i truly believed i loved her yeah
right and i did love her right but like
was it the type of love that i should be
chasing like more love bombing is more
and someone is
you maybe you could be in a relationship
you could be not being a relationship
but you're doing it to coerce them you
know like maybe it's like you want to
hook up with someone you're like but i
love you you know usually love bombing
is when you get this but i love you yeah
there's an ask afterwards
you're not doing it necessarily because
you really love you're want you want
them to believe that your feelings are
genuine so that you can get something
from that yeah yeah if you you know
there's a difference between love
blogging and being excited which people
often confuse like
two immature people can get really
caught up in their feelings have a
two-week love affair and be like i've i
love you
hook up and then one person's like so
that was too much too fast uh yeah like
i felt that two weeks ago i love bombing
that's just being really immature yeah
exactly
there's definitely a difference so like
intent definitely matters when it comes
to things like gaslighting and love
bombing but i was definitely immature
for sure and i was definitely
um
not
you know and i probably yeah i wasn't
mature because my my perception of
what it meant to be in love and the
importance of love
or
you know what it meant to be single it
was was very it was all well intentioned
you know i thought i had good role
models and look at our the tv shows that
we have you know no no
no rom-com like
they're all terrible examples totally i
totally agree
they teach us that love it doesn't it lo
all rom-coms teach us is that it does
not matter how toxic it is as long as
you make it work
and all rom-coms end up with them
getting together yeah so
if you're in a relationship and you're
not you know yeah it's not working out
you're just taught to like just push
muscle through it yeah and listen yes if
you get married and like
if all our parents all taught us like
love marriages aren't easy there's good
years in bed yeah and you definitely
have to work through that but that is
the difference between being making a
marriage work and like making a
relationship that you've known the
person for you know three months or
whatever six months when
you know you're you're so excited about
the chemistry what you feel but you've
paid no attention to that your
compatibility that's so true because
you're just blinded by the fact that
like someone probably reciprocates the
same feelings you do and you just don't
want something to not work yeah it's
it's a scary thing to like be wrong
about someone yeah and you don't i i'm
like the same ways i'm one of those
people like i try to hit
every single angle of this person to
make sure this person's right for me and
if it doesn't work i'm thinking oh even
though sometimes just relationships
don't work out because the people aren't
they could be great people individually
but just together they're not yeah they
don't work but i don't talk much about
compatibility in relationships
you don't you just think that maybe like
the some of the good times are just
enough for it to be
a great relationship but just not true
they're you have to see it from all
angles whether that's the family life or
their personal life or workouts
you look at what you want differently
when you were in your 20s what
how did you view compatibility and what
did you prioritize versus now i don't
think i can can prioritize compatibility
at all really yeah well he does he was
just saying it was more
it was more
you know
i feel something between you i like you
i'm attracted to you you know it might
have been you know my second girlfriend
it was more based off the fact that you
know my first girlfriend and i one of
the things we fought a lot about was
religion i grew up very catholic and at
the time
i again wanted to emulate my parents she
was catholic but she wasn't practicing
right so we thought about that a lot you
know and here we were two 19 20 year
olds talking about like
how we're going to raise our kids it's
just we getting ahead of ourselves
but we didn't know any better and and
that was a point of contention she
didn't like i wanted to go to church and
she didn't want to and like so when she
would
she wasn't comfortable with it i
probably
forced that on her more than i should
have like
you know and and at the time i thought
she wasn't like trying you know so like
that was something i was doing wrong and
then i met my second girl at the time
here was this girl who i was very
attracted to and very different and oh
by the way she went to church every
sunday so immediately that was just like
the biggest thing in the world right and
while that's nice
it's not everything it's there's a lot
of things we weren't yeah
that was like i i hung on to that
because that was something that was
lacking yeah for so long it's so
interesting what you cling on to in
every other like when you start jumping
into different relationships sometimes
you try to pick up oh my last
relationship didn't have this but it has
this one and this one and so instead of
kind of seeing it as a whole you're like
oh my last boyfriend wasn't that funny
so i'm gonna go for something that's
funny but maybe he's a total [ __ ] in
other ways and so yeah you're kind of
blinded by like what you i spent more
than no time in my first two
relationships ever considering how the
relationships made me feel yeah
yeah
are you analytical about things yeah i
am too i feel like i'm very heady about
i i don't think of it in terms of
emotion sometimes i think in terms of
like
kind of logical like a very sensitive
analytical that's
i am exactly the same way we're very
much people pleasers so if we're on a
date we're working so hard to make sure
that they like us instead of us thinking
hold on do we like them that is
definitely something that a lot of
people struggle right yeah so with your
show also because now that i'm like
hearing your you've gone through a lot
where you actually have a lot of
knowledge on relationships and you've
come to kind of take a step back and see
it from a
more clear standpoint rather than having
your emotions involved because you can
listen to your the people that are
calling in and giving asking for
questions you're like okay this is
actually what it is rather than
how they feel which is like maybe they
had sex with them overall what were the
questions that you got the most from
being on this having your podcast from
girls or guys or whatever
yeah it's usually stuff around
it's very like situation ship stuff okay
so things before actually defining a lot
of that yeah yeah a lot of the yeah the
stages before defining a relationship
a lot of questions about
or it could be in a relationship and
they're trying to figure out whether
they should stay or go right you know
like communication styles between people
like are they a good texter are they not
i've i recently had i honestly that was
something for the longest time i was
like what do people mean
when they're saying
he's or she's not a good texter
oh that's you
you say that a lot she is the bad texter
oh i'm a bad texter but it's only it's
like i think
have you claimed someone to be a bad
texter i claim sophia as a bad texter
because but it could be interpreted a
hundred different ways i would say she's
a bad texter because she intentionally
waits a certain amount of time based off
of no no
i have found through pulling friends and
now my facetime
that's great
that when i have found that if
in the early dating stage
because i had a friend who met a guy got
really excited about him and then the
next day
she was like i think he might be a bad
texter i was like can i ask what you
mean yeah yeah uh she's like she's a
friend of my girlfriends i was just like
what what do you mean by bad texture
she's like well he doesn't he doesn't
seem to want to
like put in the attacker
well keep in mind this was like the next
cut like like a day or two after they
had a really good first date right
and
and then and i'm like she's like he's
amazing in person we had such a good
time and i realized after talking to her
and i kind of had this epiphany is that
i feel like there's a unreasonable
expectation with some people
about like they get excited about
someone yeah and now that texting is so
prevalent
like there's there's no like need to
like wait for date two or day three just
like we can text all day throughout the
day because when i get really excited
about someone like i want to play like
20 questions or this or that or whatever
and if they don't like if they're if
that person they're into is not
not doing that that means they're a bad
texture in their mind and it's just like
wait like because it's preference like
yeah so the person you barely know
like you want you want them to who who
you claim is great in person mm-hmm
you want them to like
potentially text with you someone they
don't know at all as frequent as as
frequent as like
as a way to get to know you more yeah
when like you're really opening up the
door for a lot of miscommunication and
you don't totally know each other's
senses of humor and things like that so
i think
we've gotten so comfortable with how
accessible everyone is
via text that we some of us i think
maybe unreasonable yeah we've lost
patience we just want someone if we get
excited about someone we want them to be
excited about us and maybe they are but
maybe they're like i don't know like
i don't want to text all day long
because i'm just going to [ __ ] it up i'm
just going to say or do something stupid
people like i don't sometimes if i don't
really know you that well and the reason
why i'm called a bad texter is because i
go
i am not thinking about you 24 7. i have
other things going on but i want to talk
to you i still will answer eventually
i'm not going to completely ignore you
for eight days and then like come out of
nowhere that's ghosting but if i'm
answering every few hours or whatever it
is
that's just because we are getting to
know each other it has to be as frequent
as it is
about
setting unrealistic expectations for
people that you don't know yeah you
wanna like it's fun to be excited about
someone and it's even more fun when
they're just excited about you and it's
good to know when people aren't excited
about you because
then you have more clear expectations of
how much they're gonna make you a
priority but it's also okay if they're
not super excited about you after their
first or second date yeah like
it's hard to get excited about someone
but just because you're not excited
about the first date doesn't really mean
anything no you can get excited about
someone for all the wrong reasons i'm
sure you've heard things people talk
like the spark is like toxic do you
believe in the spark no not really i
think you get excited but like
if you're getting excited about someone
on the first date you have no idea
whether that's really who they are
you know you could get excited about
someone about like chemistry it's
chemistry spark whatever and you can
manipulate chemistry totally yeah you
can get chemistry by like having mutual
interests being part of the same church
right and having mutual friends uh you
can get chemistry by someone who maybe
you thought never would be attracted to
you right gives you attention and you're
just like oh my god i'm flattered this
is why
is there something between us like yeah
right right and you're feeling chemistry
and that's all great and maybe there's
something there but it doesn't really
say anything about like
is there something there how they're
going to treat you in a relationship
yeah are they going to make you feel
once you have expectations in a
relationship and that's why i said like
i never put any thought
into like how how my relationships made
me feel like and all the relationships i
was in there were certainly great
moments and i loved and cared about them
but like how people
make you feel when things aren't going
well or when you're not around them is
just as important when
as when they make you feel good yeah uh
i said this on my podcast the other day
is and i'm probably gonna butcher it but
we're so quick when people validate us
yeah
hey you're pretty you're sweet you're
nice you're just like thank you yeah
oh i'm just gonna take that at face
value right great no problem right but
when the people we care about like
disrespect us or disappoint us or hurt
our feelings we want to like
we want to understand it and we want to
break it down we don't want to accept it
at facebook yeah we want to just like we
want to dissect it and be like well
maybe there's a reason why they did what
they did they didn't really mean it
right maybe they're in a bet and maybe
and you know in a relationship we have
to be empathetic and we have to give
them the benefit of the doubt but that's
true it's so quick to like take
validation but we often don't take
the way people treat us at face value
and sometimes and most of the time we
just have to like see it at face value
yeah they're disrespecting us they're
treating us like an [ __ ] they're not
being considerate over time they're not
making us a priority and maybe the
reason is is that's just who they are
you're right
no that's so funny because that's why i
was saying that you get to see these
relationships and ask these girls are
asking questions or guys and you're
seeing it like as it is because you're
not emotionally investing it where
you're going oh well maybe they're doing
this because they're you're saying black
and white yeah you're seeing it black
away which is if they're not texting you
back right after
they have sex months and months later
they're probably just not that into you
or they're suspecting you or whatever it
is or i mean maybe there's something
could have happened but you're not going
to
and like put so much thought into
something in someone that's not putting
as much thought into you well that's the
thing and then people make the mistake
of again making it about them yeah so
like again like this is who they are
yeah this is how they probably treat
everyone right you know and we're so and
we're just like but but i want to be the
one person okay you want to be the one
person that changes them
like [ __ ] but they're going to treat me
like a king or a queen so like but
that's that's the wrong problem though
yeah cause that happens that was me
i'm the fixer i truly believe that i can
go into these relationships fix these
men and make them a better person and
guess what we should change that word we
should change that phrase from fixer to
like something else because picture
sounds so
like they're like they actually need
like i'm a fixer
i know it's a little toxic but also i'm
a fixer yeah it's like
what it really is is your ego being
activated and you
want you're you're trying to figure out
a way to get validated even if in the
moment you're not feeling validated yes
oh my god yes yes that's so true i want
to talk about your book
um the title really spoke to sophia and
i because we had this whole conversation
on our podcast before
and your book is titled which is coming
out when
october october
really we're really
getting the hype going i know i'm sorry
i need to read this now i need an early
copy thank you it is called work don't
text your ex happy birthday and other
advice on love sex and dating now
i love texting my ex on my birthday
because let's go back to that validation
thing we love that why shouldn't i do
that
well why do you think you should do that
exactly
see i didn't think you were going to ask
me a question um i
think i'll tell you why
because none of i wouldn't even call
them relationships because there'd be
you know a couple of months here and
there three four months so it wasn't you
know a year
i think that they never ended the way
that i would have liked
and it was always sort of toxic and it
ended horribly and the ball and the
power were never in my court yeah and so
now that i've moved on
i hope uh
and i have this opportunity to reach out
i think it's just wanting that
validation or that that showing them
that i'm so good and i'm confident
enough by the way can i just say before
the cameras rolling her answer was i
like to stir up some drama so
this is a lot different i appreciate we
had a couple minutes to come well you
were you were really honest until you
were like
after i moved on because you were like
you know i haven't gotten the answer i
wanted blah blah and then once i moved
on well no you haven't moved on cause
you're still it's still inside you're
still thinking about which is totally
okay
i mean i don't we have to be able to say
i'm not there yet i'm not totally she's
not there yet you know what my thing is
it's the reason why i used to do it
which i actually stopped because i we
talked about boyfriend well yes of
course i'm saying before i got into a
relationship we talked about this i
think in november it was and we had this
whole episode we're like it's totally
fine do it do it yeah go it's fun and
then we got so much [ __ ] from people
saying like you are so toxic it's
horrible don't do that yeah yeah and
then i think they're so harsh we still
feel like it's so hard to stop giving
advice for a little bit after the
episode after i'm like i'm sorry but we
also said this is the worst advice
you'll ever hear yeah we did say that
but we said toxic girl summer like that
was gonna come up but now we're not
gonna do that um but i used to do it
just because i don't like having any bad
things with anybody i used to go out
with i'm one of those people like i love
seeing friends so people when the
problem is is like i think i should just
let it lie and just like you don't have
to be friends with everybody i want i
don't like problems and so
i now realize like i think i'm making
more of a problem by actually bringing
back probably old feelings that they had
or
whatever it is like even if i don't feel
that way yeah there's that's the thing
there's no real productive reason to do
it doesn't matter if you're the one who
was broken up with or you're the one who
broke up with someone if you're the one
who's broken up with
you're doing it because
you know you want a way back in you know
you're you it's their birthday you wish
you were a part of their birthday you're
sad and it's just like and you convince
yourself i don't
it's the nice thing to do it's nice
i'm a bigger person i'm unbothered i've
moved on whatever [ __ ] we tell
ourselves
and so we'll just be like happy birthday
and and then just like and then like
either you don't get any response it's
not worse or you get like a thanks so no
response is going to make you feel good
because they don't want to be with you
what if you get a response saying would
love to see you soon do you want to grab
coffee or something like that and then
you're like pandora's box is open first
of all like that almost never happens
that rarely happens if they wanted you
to be a part of their birthday they
would have called
um
they yep and and also like
and so here the real answer that
question let's say let's say on the
outside chance you were dumped you were
broken up with and the person you still
wish you were with is missing you and
their birthday's coming up
and they're just like you know
maybe i shouldn't have done it you know
what a really good way to get them to
miss you even more
forget about their birthday
oh they're not acknowledging their
birthday no no nothing nothing will make
them take stock and how much they really
miss you when you've been like
moved on
yeah or you know or what if you text
them
every year for their birthday and then
intentionally miss one birthday and
they're expecting it but you don't
believe that's what it is
that's literally what it is
you got it
um yeah no that's what my dad
is the outside chance they're missing
you definitely don't text they'll miss
you more
most likely if they're not missing you
you'll just remind them of how much you
annoy them
um i love doing that uh
and and if you broke up with someone
that's not the day to remind them that
you still don't want to be with them
you're not doing something nice right by
reaching out to them on their birthday
and saying happy birthday because it's
really a selfish act you're not even
doing it do i actually want to say happy
birth no i don't care that it's your
birthday yeah it's really just me
together if you are indifferent and you
are trying to be nice you're not really
doing anything nice yeah and
it's not a way to check in to remind
them that you're okay even if they're
still not like just just let it go
reaching out and um getting attention
speaking of that you have a girlfriend
and did i read somewhere that she slid
into your dm she did especially nowadays
i'm a big believer like the dating
landscape has changed yeah i know
um we're all talking about holding on to
our power and things like that
obviously women in dating you know are
want to change the playing field and
rightfully so and we want
greater expectations of men but as a
result i think
the
in the traditional things like oh the
guy needs to chase i mean
that that can't be the same if we're
changing other things i think the
excited person needs to chase if you
know what you want if you know you're
excited you gotta go for what you want
and i've
no guy worth your time
is gonna be turned off by someone being
a woman pursuing what she wants and if
they are turned off by it they got a lot
of
therapy and other toxic traits and and
and uh toxic masculinity things they
probably need to deal with but i've
never met
a guy that's turned off by it okay say
that
guys i hung hang around with the top so
why are girls so afraid to do it i think
our society and tradition yeah it's just
you know
pressures of it also i think it's
probably
probably like or just
old school dating in society and then
nowadays it might just be a convenient
excuse because it's scary to put
yourself out there it's scary to shoot
your shot it's scary to approach
strangers and i totally agree with you
when you're saying like we're trying to
change this whole dating game with like
taking back your power and like hard
work
like being independent but then you're
also expecting someone to chase you and
all this stuff but it's good because
you're now noting if the guy isn't like
actively chasing hardcore only courting
you 24 7 night and day it doesn't mean
he's not into you
it just means that maybe he's more of a
slobber and maybe he's just taking his
own time like it's just not the same as
it used to could be a lot of things yeah
he might not be as excited about you but
you're right he might just be
just sussing it out
and then maybe you're passionate about
it and you can be the one courting him
away like in
however you want to do it but that
doesn't mean it's like the end of uh
i've also realized that there's a seems
to be a confusion with people mistaking
like holding on to their power with like
going for what you want yeah just like
if i chase that i'm not like
again natalie my girlfriend she pursued
me not only did she dm slide in my dms
but in the first nine months she was the
one who was like i think we should date
oh um good friends i've never met
someone in my life who
is i i've learned from her how to like
hold on to my power as much as she's
learned from me like i've never met
someone
who is so good i've never she
i've never met someone who never wastes
any of her energy or power that's
amazing but she's also someone who
always goes for what she wants and
there's a big difference because going
for what you want is very powerful yeah
and then not getting what you want and
handling it
really well is also very powerful yeah
when you get rejected by someone
and like people just are so used to like
people handling rejection poorly right
but if someone rejects you and you act
like you're going to be fine because you
will be yeah people are like thrown off
right you know so matt like so like
being rejected is an opportunity to show
someone like
that you'll be fine yeah and when you
show them that you'll be fine i'm not
saying they're all gonna come around but
like they're gonna remember you what's
your biggest red flag when you're dating
people
um
i hate
i i like
i think red flags are hard to like i
mean there's the obvious ones yeah being
rude to a waiter yeah of course but
i i think a red flag i try to look at
red flags on
like
how i respond
you know like
how
if i'm talk if i'm dating someone
how am i acting around this person yeah
how are they making me feel
you know do i feel insecure or do i feel
confident you know do i feel like
if i feel insecure like what what is
that either what is being triggered
either that was that person doing or how
are they making me feel like i think
those are red flags that people should
look into yeah because other red flags
are so subjective yeah they are you know
they are they depend because some people
can think that like crocs are a red flag
i don't know the door for a girl is like
a red flag
that's totally true i think being
mindful of
the energy you put out in the
relationship is like the biggest yeah
red flag or not red or green flag in
terms of
we love a green flag yeah we love green
flags you are
like the guru of all things
relationships
it's very insightful you have your you
say it exactly as it is you don't like
it also just very careful about not
talking about things i don't know right
like i don't diagnose anyone i'm not a
therapist i don't like you're only
speaking from experience i'm only just
speaking from my experiences the way you
give advice i know this sounds really
weird but the way you give advice is so
honest and blunt it reminds me of the
way my dad gives us relationships i saw
him on one of your shows and i was like
he's like jesus whatever he knows what
he's talking about he does i'll tell you
this most breakup texts or calls or
conversations that we've had with guys
are completely 100 slice words yeah so
my dad's essentially breaking up with
you but he's just so he's like a savant
when it comes to relationships he also
knows a man i mean he's a guy so he goes
okay well you're thinking of it like
this but i'm telling you as a guy that
he's not or he's doing this and so he'll
kind of he doesn't fluff his answers
i don't know how many you've done with
your dad but i saw one i was like oh i
think i i think it was
actually when you when you i think you
commented on it and that was the one
we're like oh we really want you on um
and he was talking about how uh things
that guys do early on in a relationship
is pretty much an indicative of how
they're gonna be in the rest of the time
so he goes don't like waste time um he
says don't place so much stress on also
like when you're supposed to fall in
love because this yeah this like clock
because i'm someone that always was like
um by 25 i need to do this date this
person for three years then get married
then this and then i started listening
to sarah blakely i love uh the owner of
spanx and she always was like you know
what
i want to build my own career and if i
find my husband i'll find him knobs and
she found her husband at 35 she's
married she has four kids and i was
thinking that she made it so simple just
do you
what is needed for you what is going to
be best for you will come to you if you
don't force it yeah so you definitely
make a lot of bad relationship choices
off of timelines we set for ourselves
when we're 18. or thinking like yeah yes
exactly what did we know then listen
because they have this or they do this
one thing like okay your ex went to
church and you're like oh perfect like
that's that's it this is all i need but
you realize like that's really like
natalie's probably totally different
from her so it's like it's crazy that
you're like okay i realized what when i
took a step back and i started to
understand myself more you don't really
need to put so much stress on it it's
tough yeah i know so yeah so my dad has
really enforced that yeah um it's kind
of hard because i know my mom met my dad
when she was like 19. so it's like oh
very different like different time
nick i'm about to sit on my bed and
stare at my ceiling for the next four
hours just absorbing
this conversation i feel like i got 10
smarter in my relationship brain thank
you so much thanks for having me you
guys are great awesome you're awesome
you guys need to go check out his
podcast it's the vile files they can
listen everywhere yeah anywhere you you
can watch it too do i put any plugs uh
instagram files follow me on tiktok or
instagram nickvile
i love your tech talks
i sometimes get worried they get like
annoying no they're great oh i like
people i'm always like the guy like i
swear to god they pop up
probably once a week in my life i like
the personal ones that you do like just
giving straight advice not even on the
podcast like that is smart i think
sometimes it gets exhausting because
it's just like i feel like i'm lecturing
people but yeah but you know what people
are meaning to talk to you for those
like how many lost people listen
and then next week you guys are coming
on my podcast we are we're gonna be
honest we're talking some pop culture
we're giving people text advice so thank
you guys so much and we will see you
next tuesday bye
[Music]